can you talk a little bit about the
casting process and how you ended up
with six amazing performers yeah they're
great they're there we got we got really
lucky well it happened in a traditional
way insofar as we have a great casting
director it starts there Gina McCarthy
who's amazing and because we live in the
world with the World Wide Web
we saw kids from pretty much every
english-speaking country in the world I
think you know we were I saw audition
tapes from certainly all over the US all
over Canada all over the UK Australia
and New Zealand South Africa and then we
brought in the kids Los Angeles the ones
it could come George McKay who plays
boat oven and Nicolas Hamilton who plays
relyon well done as is from Australia so
they did their callbacks via Skype with
him in fact and I brought them to the
other kids to LA and we did we played
theatre games and dado improvisation and
and then and then we had a bootcamp
beforehand I was just gonna ask that
they did they know going in what they
were going to be expected to do because
I assuming they were really rock
climbing and they were really skinning
animals and yes was that was that a hard
sell for any oh they love that idea but
you I mean we couldn't expect that the
children could rock climb and play
instruments and fight and know how to
butcher dress a deer and a stop and I
wanted to skin everything they saw it's
not archery I mean as soon as they were
cast this is George McKay was cast he
was doing four hours of yoga de samme
isler and analyse Fausto who played the
two teenage girls they butchered a sheep
and because I wanted them to learn some
basic knife skills and everyone was
playing music every day they were rock
climbing every day we did martial arts
I've done some Brazilian jiu-jitsu and
MMA and I had one of my coaches come up
and teach them like basic grappling
skills and we did music every day yeah
and so were you ready for all of these
challenges you go and you already know
Rock climbs and I don't
I have a future in rock climbing or
playing the bagpipe legal also had
backed by blessings yeah okay or playing
the guitar well either but it was a
great it was fortunate that the
producers that the production company
allowed Matt to do things that way that
we got to meet not just for to hone the
skills we'd have to show on film but
just to get to know each other it was a
great way purpose of it is not to like
anyone to learn to master any of these
skills in 18 weeks three weeks or
whatever where what time we had that's
impossible it's really for them talking
to know each other and to bond and to
begin to look at Vigo as their father
and their friend to trust him and well
could you both talk a little bit about
what your own experiences as as fathers
that you brought to you know first of
the script of the film and to your
performance in it I mean since the role
of the father plays is so key to to the
entire film the genesis of the movie
came out of my questions about
Parenthood and about being a father I
don't know that I mean I always say
endings are meaning and you've all seen
the movie so for me that's the the
answer the questions I had is at the end
of the movie so I didn't really work
anything out that I didn't know
beforehand the working out part was
writing the script I think production is
as we all know about time and money and
there's never enough of either so most
of the time what I tried to do on set
was create an environment where all the
other interpretive artists could come
and do their work and it's you know
patience and play we show up to explore
and to play that's really my job I think
the questions of what I bought brought
to bear as the father was just that I
had a lot of confusion about being a
father and in many ways the part that he
plays is aspirational as a kind of
fantasy of mine that I wish I could be
that that guy I mean obviously as I read
the script the first time well first of
all I wondered why is it why does they
have this title what's it about
first few pages I was hooked but I had a
initially incorrect idea about where it
was headed it looked like very well
written
you know the dialog was good as 10 maybe
15 pages in and I thought okay this is a
a movie about I suppose it's a liberal
you know utopian fantasy right and that
fair enough but it's a kind of a limited
audience Bobby for this but it's it's
well-written and and I I assume that
what you would see is this family this
father and his six kids their enemies
would be or their obstacles would be
conservative thinking and conservative
people and there would probably be some
humor involved and but that's
essentially would it be about and it
turns out to be a much more complex than
that you know the father was flawed and
you know and I quickly realized that the
title was somewhat ironic and that you
could even have a question mark at the
end of it if you wanted to but I I
obviously thought about how I had raised
my son who's not 28 how my father had
raised me and his father him and just
different models
I thought about family about my family
immediately but I also thought you know
you know I guess this larger context
about communication about the problems
with not interacting with others not
really listening to points of view that
are that are quite different than your
own or from people that you might not
like or agree with that you might be
afraid of as we're making a movie we
talked a lot about how that applied in
some way to society and I think that
what's great about the story like any
story that makes you that's good enough
it's well-written enough and and in this
case well-made enough that you think
about larger issues outside of the
movies story I thought about at the time
and even more now that it's come out the
way things are going in the country
right now
there there is a problem communication
with people not listening to each other
in this movie in large part it made me
think about that constantly we talked
about that a lot that you know when
people don't listen to each other when
they isolate and there is an internet
interaction as both events as in the
story you know I everything I know is
from books you know and living in
isolation and there's their handicap
socially you know well in scripting the
the movie and in building the
performance are you are you planning on
how you want the audience to feel about
Ben as the character changed I mean in
other words to that you're building so
that the audience has sympathy for him
and then and another scene they're
actually against him or hostile towards
him we didn't talk about in terms of
performance I didn't say you know now's
the time that we don't like you um but
but but certainly I think but certainly
that was built into the DNA of the
narrative I mean I like movies where
your allegiance or alliance or who you
are following or supporting or agreeing
with changes constantly I think that
makes for complex narrative and I think
it's also how you know that replicates
life more accurately I think none of us
think we're the villain of our own movie
we all think we're the hero of our own
movie and we all go into most I think we
all go in with the best of intentions as
does the character so yes I mean I and I
talked to Frank Langella about that a
great deal when we when he was first
cast and we were talking about the part
I said you know I think you're
antagonistic towards Viggo but your two
videos character but you're not the
antagonist and he loved that idea and
really wanted to play that and he got
weird job I mean by the way I mean it's
hard to do doesn't have as much screen
time definitely he did a wonderful job
and with that relatively little screen
time he got that across it was a complex
character and you actually you can't
help just the way it's written but
especially the way he played it you
can't help but say to yourself no matter
where you're coming from
he's right he's got a point in several
instances and that's what's great about
the script the characters are layered
each of the kids I mean it's it's rare
that you see teenage girls for example
who aren't reacting to a teenage boy or
some male figure
reacting against or pining for or
annoyed at their thinking for themselves
I mean in the characters I mean it's one
of the best written scripts that I've
read in a long time maybe ever where all
the characters stand out no matter how
much time they're on screen and and I
thought that both Franklin and dad did a
great job of surprising you because
you're expecting even though the stories
become quite complex by the time you
reach their house you're waiting for
them to be these caricatures or ours
that's first actually with the Kathryn
Hahn Steve's on section of the film with
that with those characters as well as
that you know she says everyone's just
doing the best they know how we're just
all trying to do the best we can and I
think that this deep truth in that
statement right so how long were you
actually in production I mean we were
watching we get to shoot exactly we shot
for 39 days which is a lot for an
independent film I think it was was it
Dustin Hoffman who recently was talking
about films in the 70s and said that
they shot for a hundred days for the
Graduate when someone asked him why were
movie so good in the 70s and he said
well among other things a film with no
special effects was just people talking
we had a hundred days mm-hmm you know
independent films largely get 20 22 days
so 39 days sounds like a lot but then
you put in the equation that we have six
kids in every scene do you think about
covering six kids and then because of
child labor laws which are a great thing
but make it impossible to shoot the
youngest ones for more than five six
hours many location any locations
reserved because it's a road movie where
we do different locations every day and
many of them are really in the middle of
nowhere
we're two States and we have two to kind
of stunts and with kids and to musical
numbers with kids so it was we were it
was it was hard I mean it's always hard
I mean I think every you never have as I
said you never have enough time or money
but well and were you you said that you
already somewhat prepared for the
outdoor scenes and for the the lifestyle
that Ben has created but were you also
familiar with the with the writers that
he you know teaches the kids with the
philosophies with the political
positions that most of them I mean Matt
with very generously sent sent me a box
with a lot of books that you some of
which we got the rights to use in the
movie and I had read all of them there
was some there were some that are about
special high-performance athlete
training something any Olympic athletes
yeah and that I didn't pretty good and
yeah yeah but that was and it was great
to share them the kids and the kids even
a little ones they were interested you
know that boss was full of books and the
team's first day of shooting I gave them
all a backpack filled with books mm-hmm
and half of them looked at me like
really we just finished the summer and
you're giving me a backpack full of
books but you know there were there was
like Howard Zinn's people's history of
the United States for children there's a
book for kids it's a great book and then
the older ones I gave the the grown-up
version and yeah it was an amazing
collaboration and a beautiful film thank
you both for the movie and thank you for
20s thank you all thank you very much
thanks a lot